the African Union has given the leaders
of South Sudan one last chance to form a
government the country has been locked
in conflict since 2013 when President
Salva Kiir fired he's then vice
president Riek Machar
he accused him of crossing a coup the
situation escalated in 2016 when
fighting again erupted between forces
loyal to the two men Sudan stepped in
and mediated but a peace deal signed in
September 2018 has never been
implemented and last week the two men
failed to meet a deadline to form a
government unity government that would
be now in the five years of conflict
nearly 400,000 people have been killed
more than four million have fled the
country and others have been displaced
within South Sudan it's not much but at
least it's safe the town of Tambora has
welcomed nearly 200 displaced families
this year
Angelina witnessed horror in her home
village but here she has found a room
for hope a village was destroyed some of
her relatives and all the elders were
killed I'm praying to God that peace
will be implemented for country since
independence from Sudan eight years ago
the people of South Sudan have hardly
seen peace millions have ended up in
refugee camps because of fighting
between government forces and rebel
groups these are the men who can help
bring peace President Salva Kiir in the
Hat and rebel leader react mature the
peace deal they signed is supposed to
unite their fighters longtime enemies
into one army but a lack of funds has
delayed that plan as they also postpone
forming a joint government I know the
extension does not give you assurance
about security in South Sudan and it
does not help to reduce your suffering
something that has been bothering me for
a very long time
we tried our best to explain that the
permanent ceasefire is holding and
generally there is no war has kept
development away so South Sudan depends
on the outside world international
partners keep sending aid but they
remain doubtful about the political will
amongst this nation's leaders until that
commitment is evident South Sudan's road
to recovery remains rough GWS to me
Oladipo has done extensive reporting on
South Sudan's conflict he's also
specializing in security issues across
the continent good to see you told me so
why can't Salva Kiir and Rickman Shaw
implement the peace deal that they've
signed which of the two of these
gentlemen is causing the problem
well at the moment neither wants to be
blamed for the delay there first of all
blaming money they're saying they don't
have enough funds to put together this
government and put together the army
that's supposed to integrate both their
forces as I said in the piece South
Sudan because of all its troubles has
not been able to raise enough revenue
from its oil because a lot of the oil
production has had to stop and and so
it's relying a lot on aid from the
outside right but even that I mean the
world right now there's so many other
issues around every country is having
its own troubles they can't just be
throwing money at South Sudan and South
Sudan has had these problems with
funding to the point where the elections
last year which is supposed to be held
in 2018 were postponed to 2021 and then
now you have this joint coalition
government that they're supposed to
implement that's not in place but apart
from the issue of funding there's still
others to do it even just the two sides
agreeing about you know the makeup of
this unity army they're supposed to form
whose forces are gonna be where border
lines about who controls what territory
you know right into so there's so much
right so the money is one issue but
there various other issues as you as you
correctly point out what do we have to
make of the mediation that has been
by Uganda's you were a museveni because
it looks like the US and even the
African Union is getting annoyed judging
by the language we saw in again there
was another delay well when this deal
was signed first of all there was a lot
of skepticism because these two men have
signed deals in the past we're going
back as far as 2013 when they've been
signing deals and breaking them and so
this deal is signed again and a lot of
observers looked and thought you know
this is this one's not going to hold yet
again but if you look at the the apart
from your Amos ebony the President of
Uganda and other regional leaders
they've been the ones who've been most
involved in trying to bring these two
men together and trying to make it look
like it's a local sort of regional
solution to this problem as opposed to
you know the outside world like the u.s.
let's talk about the US and so the top
diplomat in Washington has basically
threatened action he said we will
reassess our engagement with Juba what
does that mean
well it's trying to put pressure on
these these two men to find a deal and
get things together because think about
it there's still 12 million people who
fled from their homes because of the
fighting 7 million what the UN calls
severely food insecure which means they
can not feed themselves when they're
hungry
so South Sudan is depending on the
outside world and the US and other
countries are saying you we can't just
keep our our cash flow going you need to
find a solution and that's a billion
dollars in the case of the UN the u.s.
right it is right tell me a lot of poor
DW news Africa thank you